do not apologize to the mob
it's very good to apologize in good
faith to people who are going to accept
your apology and good faith in your
in your life but when the mob is coming
after you you really can't apologize i
i saw this yesterday with this poor
schlub
this this fellow winston marshall who is
a musician in mumford and sons i
actually really like mumford and sons i
know maybe i'm just
a a child of the i was a teenager in the
20 teens so i
i really liked mumford and sons but this
guy i think he's a good musician
and he espoused a very interesting point
of view the other day on twitter he said
congratulations andy no finally had
the time to read your important book
you're a brave man you know andy no
a friend of the show friend of mine he
wrote this book about antifa he has been
targeted more than just about anybody by
antifa
he suffered a brain bleed because of
these antifa militants and he's got an
excellent book
out there detailing it because the
narrative that we're being told about
antifa
is very different from the reality we're
told that antifa is just an idea well
ideas don't give you brain bleeds
so this mumford and sons musician reads
the book
says okay you know i enjoyed the book
and then the backlash came they were
very
very upset that he would read a memoir
by a guy who got a brain bleed by
leftist
terrorists and they're even more upset
that he would endorse the book
so he issues an apology mr mumford and
sons writes
over the past few days i have come to
better understand the pain
caused by the book that i endorsed i
have offended
not only a lot of people i don't know
but also those closest to me
including my bandmates and for that i'm
truly sorry
as a result of my actions i'm taking
time away from the band to examine my
blind spots
for now please know that i realize how
my endorsements have the potential to be
viewed as approvals of hateful divisive
behavior
i apologize as this was not at all my
intention
oh buddy buddy buddy buddy
i know exactly what happened here
and you are getting very very
very bad advice here's what happened
this guy
winston marshall i'm just i i know that
i'm just pulling this off the top of my
head but i'm
i would be willing to bet a lot of money
that something like this is what
happened
he comes out and he sends a tweet and
says i enjoyed this book wow this is
very interesting book you should
consider reading it
then maybe a band mate or two
maybe someone and maybe some marketing
gal
in the publisher's office or some maybe
some people
around him get upset about it
then the twitter trend happens and when
you trend on twitter you feel like the
world is collapsing and around you
then he's getting the deluge of hate the
deluge of mean tweets and
emails and people who are in politics
are accustomed to this
we get that sort of thing basically
every single day so you just don't take
it
all that seriously you know how to deal
with it if you're a pure entertainer
you're really not used to that kind of
thing
and so it's very jarring when it happens
now because we're living in the cancel
culture
where the left attacks people and ruins
their careers for saying perfectly
ordinary things
this guy winston is in total survival
mode he says oh my gosh i'm starting to
lose things this is bad this has never
happened i've just gotta
stop the bleeding i've just gotta stop
whatever's happening
and some unscrupulous people are gonna
go in and they're gonna say hey you've
gotta
issue a perfectly unqualified apology
and you've gotta step away for a while
but then it'll all be better then you'll
get
your career back then you'll get your
reputation back then you'll get
invited to all the same parties then
you'll get all your money back
and this poor guy believed them
but it's not true it's not true
look in my own career in politics and
media i've
had some moments like this where there's
a lot of pressure to cave into a mob
i know basically everybody who is in uh
politics and media has had these moments
do not do it dude it is you only lose by
doing it
you you can't unless you feel you've
really done something wrong and
egregious and then you've got to deal
with that on your own but
if you're just talking about something
like this you can never ever
win by giving in to the mob and the
people advising you to do so are lying
to you
they're not that you you think that you
can preserve something that is already
lost
you think that you can get them to like
you again you won't you won't
i i would encourage this fella mr
marshall if he listens to this show
if he reads andy noah's book there's a
fair chance he listens to this show
uh don't do it reverse course stick to
your guns go out there and defend andy
now
at least you'll keep your dignity you'll
keep more of your career i think
if you end up doing that if you show
that you've got a spine but even if you
even if you're gonna you're gonna lose
your career either way
at a at a certain level of this kind of
a moment right
that seems like the likely thing and so
at least keep your dignity
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
michael knowles show to check out the
full episode
hit the link in the description or
download the michael knowles show
wherever you listen to podcasts
[Music]
you